[Musique]
recevoir tous nos amis j'ai bien cru que
nous n'arriverions jamais nounours
transporte un si gros paquet que notre
petit nuage a bien failli chavirer pas
trop
c'est un paquet de ma soeur imee via je
veux en faire la surprise à pape rhône
nicolas et j'y vais donc pas beau il
fait attention de ne pas tomber nounours
tôt ce mois nounours vous ne me tue les
enfants
bonsoir du color
bonsoir pas preneur cellou et des mois
les enfants c'est un colis de ma soeur
emilie
[Musique]
le pont sur la table parce qu'ils sont
pressés ou là
ce que ça doit être bon mais c'est bien
mieux que ça des marrons glacés une
lettre pour moi en ma chère soeur
bien sûr bien sûr
donc c'est bon convaincant dans sa
lettre d'affairé milliards ah oui voyons
voir mon cher frais un grand merci pour
ta longue lettre si intelligent j'ai
remis dans notre europe
tout va pour le mieux où nous sommes ce
qui semble assez mara est là content de
savoir que tu travailles beaucoup et que
tu fais de beaux voyages avec ton patron
du tout les enfants
il fait pas tout manger laissez moi un
peu qu'est ce qu'elle dit apprête à
faire rémi toto et fanfan ont beaucoup
grandi depuis cet été ils sont très chou
et mange presque tout seul les chéris il
aimerait beaucoup venir passer quelques
jours de vacances chez nicolas et
pimprenelle et revoir leur cher tonton
qu'en penses tu
cher frérot écris-moi mille caresse ta
soeur qui t'aiment mbia cher ruby ils
ont mangé tous les marrons vous êtes
petit diable on avoue on lit on lui
grard ne ment si vous croyez commune
veut vont venir vous voir
ils sont bien élevés
oh
[Musique]
j'ai géré et on verra où dorment une
bonne nuit mon nom
dino qui viendront quand même que tu
veux on verra je vais y refus de nicolas
et pimprenelle
[Musique]
et voilà nicolas et punis il a look car
il a été trop gourmand à haute voix la
nounours où ils passeront alors tu as de
bonnes nouvelles de ta famille comment
se porte t neveu vont sans doute venir
nous voir
patron c'est une excellente idée tous
nos petits amis vont être très content
bonne nuit des enfants aller vite au
dodo et faites de beaux rêves
bonne nuit
[Musique]
oh